I do not think that I should apologize.
Truth is never illustrated through the use of violence.
This is one of the guiding principles...
...that sits at the core of the illuminated thinking...
...created by the man known to the world as Mahatma, the great soul;...
...moral and spiritual teacher,...
...founding father of India.
And even when provoked,...
...he would refuse to denounce his aggressors...
...ever more convinced...
...that nonviolence is the only way to combat violence itself.
On the basis of his traumatic experiences in South Africa,...
...Gandhi developed the concept of Satyagraha,...
...that literally means "adhering unflinchingly to the truth."
As Gandhi saw it, physical force is only used by weak people.
Real strength resides in a person's capacity to express their ideals.
On the 11th of September 1906,...
...Gandhi publicly proclaimed his philosophy for the first time.
Public support was virtually universal.
One must never oppose arrest.
One must never oppose the law.
One must never respond to violence with violence,...
...but one must strive to affirm vigorously the will of the people...
...and uphold religious freedom.